did you know tennyson at all oh yeah i
did i did my
graduate work in shopping lines with sam
at the comedy store were you a drug guy
too no i was a drug guy i haven't done
drugs in 13 years but when i was 21
years old
right i went out to lost it i went met
him
dude dude you hung with it it was 1987
i went out there to be a comic i get a
job as the doorman at the comedy store
right and it's right before his time
it's right before he breaks right yeah
i didn't know this guy i'd seen him once
on tv and quite frankly he didn't like
him it was like he screams a lot yeah i
don't know
what kind of comedy is that and i meet
carl it was the weirdest [ __ ] time
i met carl lebeau you know carl yeah i
know the first time i met him
i thought i was a pretty you know mr
rock and roll dude i thought i could
handle the drugs and you know i was
doing drugs on my own
so i'm living in this house and sam goes
in he's we go one on one right so i'd
never met sam before
and we're sitting there and he's doing
we're doing blow right
and it's just me and him he's right here
he's looking me in the eye go look me in
the eyes marin
can't trust a man doesn't look me in the
eyes so i'm like i don't know this guy
yeah and i'm looking him in the eyes i'm
like okay i'm doing it
you know and he's giving me the sam riff
and like you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
help you out man you know and the whole
bit
all right and then we run out of blow uh
oh and he's
uh and this is the first time i meet
this guy it's like four in the morning
he's like yeah we need more blowing i'm
like
i i don't know i don't know anybody he's
like wait you got a car
so we get in my car this is the first
time i met the guy yeah and we're
driving down sunset and he's like in and
out of consciousness and it's like you
know
i know that look yeah you know what he's
like and and like and then he snaps up
at one point he goes i don't even know
you you could kill me
and i'm like where are we going what are
we doing but we drive to this guy's
house
it's four in the morning you know we
mean sam rings the intercoms i said sam
you know my god where are we somewhere
yeah i'd be on crescent heights or
whatever
and we go up to this door and sam's like
knocking on the door
and this guy opened he opens the door
he's in the bathrobe you know he's got
long blonde hair and he's like could you
just be cool my roommate's sweeping so
you got anything
and we go into this guy's room and uh
you know and sam just
falls on the floor and he goes you got
any you got any booze and then
like for some reason all this guy had
was miniatures
and he gives sam miniature bottles of
booze yeah he gives
like a little baba vodka so he gives a
little fat sam who's on the floor of
this
mini smirnoff bottle she's just looks
like a giant
it's like gulliver in the land of food
exactly right so he's drinking this and
he passes out
and i don't know the guy the drug dealer
i don't know sam really and i'm like all
right well i guess i'm gonna take off
he's like you're not leaving him here
right he's your responsibility i'm like
what do you mean
i don't want him to pull a belushi on me
so now i got to walk you know
sam you know get him up and get him out
and get him back to where i live and he
passes out on the floor like you're his
nurse
yeah well where should it happen and did
you see him piss on somebody like
he pissed on my bed why that you want to
hear that
i mean i don't know what is that this
was for a reason
that he pissed on your bed yeah it was
it was an interesting reason i'll tell
you the story
back then the comedy store is its own
universe and there was this guy that
used to hang around his name was dave
he was a satanist he had like a
pentagram tattooed over his heart he had
you know weird illuminate tattoos he was
a hangar on he'd hang out
right sam couldn't stand them all right
so
my job ultimately became like sam on
monday nights it was no cover night
so i was the head door guy and i was
sort of part of it but he never let me
on the inner circle thank god i you know
i got spit out by that crew but
what he would do he would show up about
11 30. and you know he's there
and uh you know and and sam comes and
you know already like
because i'm so involved with the energy
of the thing i'm like oh there's gonna
be a problem
you know dave's at the table and sam
would hold court and yeah you know all
kinds of people
so at some point the party's going on
and
uh i should i should preface this by
saying like two days before this party
sam had brought all his guitars and amps
up to the house and we had a jam session
right he was always jamming
yeah we had a big jam session out on the
patio over holly it was fun
i couldn't keep up with him in car but
we had a good time and all his guitars
and equipment were in my little bedroom
because they didn't they didn't bring
him home yeah
i need to set that up all right so so so
here's the party it's going on somewhere
on day two you know dave stands up and
goes i'm going to tell anton levay about
you
right and the head of the satanist
church a clown right
and uh yeah i'm going to tell him you're
not a real satanist
so sam just stands up and he throws a
drink in this guy's face and he starts
pounding on him
oh my god just beating him up yeah yeah
and yeah that was his style
drink boom you know so i'm like oh man
so you know dave his
his shirt's ripped open he's like he's
running around and i
i pull him aside so you gotta get out of
here he goes i'm not leaving and i'm
like you gotta get out of here it's
great you're ruining the party and
you're getting beat up
and he is but he's not leaving he's not
leaving so i'm like all right i'm gonna
put you in my room
right we're gonna and you can you lock
yourself in there and and
sam can't get to you right and i i gotta
go cause i got a friend coming in
a buddy of mine from boston is coming in
i told him all about like how i'm living
in l.a i got to pick him up at the
airport
so i put dave in my room i go the
airport
i pick up bill i take him to his hotel
and i sweep over there because i don't
even want to go back over there right he
wants to be part of that that's right
right so the next morning so this is
whoever's been going has been going at
least two days now right so we go over
to the house because i'm going to show
them the house
so we walk in and and sam's still there
with a couple other people all right so
the party is dwindled down to just
two or three people and sam doing blow
at 10 in the morning
oh my god and i walk in i you know first
i go over to my room the door has been
kicked in
okay and all the equipment's gone your
[ __ ] is broken
and i'm like i don't know what's going
on so me and bill walk into this room
and yeah you know carl's there and a
couple other people and and
i just stand there at the table and sam
looks up and he goes i pissed on your
bed marin
why you want to know why and i go yeah i
do want to know why sam because
you at that [ __ ] sweep with my guitars
the weird moment there's a beat and i
look at my friend bill and i say i told
you i knew him all right